let me ask you something what do you think is the most important skill
your child will need in the next 10 years
coding mathematics
a second language
those are good answers but they are not the right answer
because here is what the data from over 1,000 employers
representing 14 million workers actually tells us
The World Economic Forum's Future of Jobs Report 2025
projects that 39% of core workplace skills will change by 2030
not some skills nearly four in every 10 skills that are valued today
will either disappear or become less important within this decade
and 59% of the global workforce will need to be reskilled
that includes the people teaching your children right now
so the question is not just what jobs are coming
the question is what kind of human being do you need to raise
to thrive in a world being reshaped by artificial intelligence
the answer is both simpler and more demanding than most parents expect
your child needs two things working together
technical fluency and deep human capability
not one or the other
both woven together into what researchers call a t shape profile
deep expertise in at least one area
combined with broad skills that cross discipline and adapt to change
let us start with the technical side
the No. 1 fastest growing skill on the World Economic Forum list
is not so coding it is artificial intelligence literacy
understanding what artificial intelligence is
how it works where it fails
and when to trust it a child who cannot critically
evaluate an artificial intelligence output
is not prepared for the world that is coming
they are vulnerable to it
the second critical technical skill is computational thinking
not memorizing programming syntax
but learning to break complex problem into smaller parts
recognize patterns and design step by step solutions
this is the mental framework that makes someone effective
whether they are using artificial intelligence tools
managing a team or launching a business
third is data literacy
we live in a world where artificial intelligence systems
are built entirely on data
child who can read interpret
question and challenge data
is a child who can understand
the world more clearly
than those who simply accept to what a screen tells them
fourth is digital fluency
not just using devices but understanding how information travels
how systems can be manipulated
how to protect privacy and how to evaluate whether something is true
in an era of generated content and deepfakes
this is a survival skill
these four technical capabilities form the foundation
but here is what will truly separate your child from the machines
because this is where the story gets remarkable
MIT Sloan researchers develop a framework called ipok
it identifies five categories of human capability
that artificial intelligence cannot replicate
and here is the extraordinary finding
every single one of these capabilities is associated with employment
growth not decline
the first is empathy
the ability to genuinely understand what another person is feeling
to read a room to respond to human emotion with human sensitivity
no language model feels no algorithm grieves or celebrates
empathy is irreplaceable the second is perspective
the capacity for ethical judgment
moral reasoning
and seeing a situation from multiple angles before acting
this is what leaders do this is what doctors do at the bedside
this is what parents do every single day
artificial intelligence can generate options
it cannot carry moral weight
the third is originality
genuine creativity not remixing existing patterns
which is what artificial intelligence does
but generating truly novel ideas from lived experience
imagination
and the kind of intuition that comes from being alive in the world
the greatest artists entrepreneurs
and scientists of the next generation will be valued
precisely because they think in ways machines cannot predict
the fourth is connection the ability to inspire
to lead to communicate a vision that makes people want to follow
this is the quality of great teachers
great coaches great founders
it requires trust and trust requires a human being on the other side
the fifth is human drive greet betso perseverance
the ability to push through failure
adapt after disappointment and keep moving when the path disappears
artificial intelligence does not know what it means to struggle
your child shaped by real challenges does
Workday's 2026 research confirms that 83% of business leaders
believe artificial intelligence is making human skills more important
not less let that land for a moment
the smarter artificial intelligence gets
the more valuable your humanity becomes